I was on this thing called JK news and
you can see it on YouTube I'll be
straight up with you man I was nervous
when I got in there I thought that these
people were thinking that they were
better than me and they weren't and it
was just this weird fear in my head you
know I got in there and it's like a half
hour till we start and they're eating
Asian food early in the morning I'm not
being racist I love Asians dude give me
an Asian dude I'll put them in my shirt
I'll hug them I'll start a family bro I
put cinnamon on them and start a family
of cinnamon Asians never seen never seen
by anyone rare them Cas and then we got
started and it was fun but you know what
I realized I never hung out with Asian
people that much they had Vietnamese
Japanese Dragon Ball Z was in that
got hella Asian some of the
white hosts that I've been around the
white culture where we were afraid to
speak our mind and those people are
fearless guess I thought that they would
be more fearful for some reason it was
inspiring I got in there and they were
Fearless they shared what they really
felt they weren't from a bad place but
they were just very real and it was
refreshing that stuff's called JK news
it's all out there on YouTube if you
want to check it out